how is everything good with you and
whack at this point now everything solid
thing everything is closure chris yeah
yeah so are you officially because i saw
the empire logo on the back of the uh
the new album
um
you're officially independent um or
what's your situation now the situation
i'm still in talks with cash money
you know about making everything right
regular cash money cash money west i
mean uh it's cash money in the u.s okay
okay but it's cash money everything
under cash money i'm saying but his cash
money wags at the end of the day uh
but uh yeah i've been talking with them
i've been talking about whacking uh and
birdman
you know uh we agreed that
you know i'm saying we gotta finish
where we started right right right but
um
before that
it was just it was an independent
situation
and uh i did like a little project deal
with empire you know i'm saying just for
this project
see how it go and uh
everything
you know went smooth but
like right now as of like like
officially i'm independent but
more than likely
i'm gonna go to cash money right again
you're end up going cash money again
yeah yeah i feel it's uh it's only right
because weren't you the first artist on
cash money west exactly there it is yeah
yeah and then you ended up getting
incarcerated right
um
that is one thing i feel like with you
and in particular
there's a lot of like
what ifs
you know what i mean because you have so
much momentum behind you
and then you end up incarcerated or you
end up in some [ __ ] like
do you feel like um
you kind of had to go through all that
to kind of
really appreciate your position in the
music industry definitely bro uh
like in the beginning i ain't gonna lie
i did
exactly
like what you're not supposed to do but
i was a young high head like i had the
mindset i got now
when i first um got my deal and
everything
like [ __ ] would have been totally
different
because you know i got like a way more
level head on me and i'm way more mature
so
uh i just feel like like you got to go
through life experiences to learn i
learned from it though definitely you
know i'm saying sometimes you'll be real
detrimental to your journey but
it's about how you get back up how you
bounce back how you bounce back bro and
i feel like
at the end of the day i told myself like
i can't let nothing stop me
you know
[ __ ] might not go as planned
but just stay on course